alors quelle est l'atmosphère à l'heure
où on se parle dans la ville de nice on
arrivait à plusieurs sentiments ici un
fort sentiment de colère de personnes de
tous types de communautés qui se sont
regroupés devant la basilique
évidemment la peur et puis le
recueillement c'est le moment du
recueillement c'est pourquoi autour de
moi juste à ma gauche des jeunes sont
venus avec des bougies qu'ils vont
enflammer au fur et à mesure avec
quelques fleurs ce sont des jeunes
également de communes de confession
musulmane de confession chrétienne il ya
également des athées ici donc si vous
voulez l'heure est au recueillement et
je pense que le peuple de nice vraiment
et soudés ils se connaissent en fait dès
que nous parlons à des riverains ici ils
disent les niçois sont gentils ils
s'aiment les communautés coexistent
c'est ce qu'on est en train de voir en
ce moment je rappelle les faits la
barbarie de ce matin trois morts nous
avons rencontré des paroissiens qui les
connaissaient qui connaissait notamment
le sacristain qui est décédé il ya
également deux victimes femmes tandis
que l'agresseur a priori un tunisien
d'une vingtaine d'années venait
d'arriver en france il ya quelques mois
en octobre après être passé par l'italie
voilà où nous en sommes dans une grande
émotion juste devant la basilique notre
dame à nice je vous propose d'écouter
des riverains on vit ensemble
mon mari que le tien français ça nous a
jamais empêché de vivre ensemble et
ruine et ça fait 28 ans que je suis
mariée avec un français qui n'est pas
musulman
mes parents l'ont acceptée et tout le
monde ils ont accepté
alors arrêtons arrêtons de faire des
bêtises
en utilisant le nom des musulmans
c'est la foi
que vous soyez russes et européens
africains américains
vous avez la foi vous venez ici les
pauvres dames qu'ils étaient là pourquoi
les égorger pourquoi les égorger vincent
le demandait rien à personne le
sacristain je le connaissais je
connaissais deux filles je connais sa
fin je connais sa maman je chante dans
la même chorale que lui des fois mais
c'est triste c'est lâche ça m'a ému
jarrier pas entendre ce qu'on me disait
au point de départ je pensais qu'on
parlait de notre dame de paris
malheureusement on allons devoir
certainement plusieurs églises
notre-dame en france
j'ignore les autres mais bon c'est
triste que ni soy frappé ainsi que
d'autres grandes villes de france
vous vous rendez compte de l'émotion ici
avec des personnes qui peuvent circuler
de nouveau puisque l'avenue jacques
médecin avait été bloqué la circulation
a été rétablie et désormais des voisins
des riverains affluent devant cette
basilique notre dame un mot vous
attendait d'ailleurs la cloche derrière
moi aujourd'hui le glas a sonné à 15h
dans les églises de nice et puis
emmanuel macron donc le président est
venu rendre visite aux forces de l'ordre
il a été accueilli par le maire de nice
christian estrosi il a annoncé un
renforcement du pouvoir militaire
défense militaire je vous rappelle je
vous propose pardon de l'écouter si nous
sommes attaqués
une fois encore c'est pour les valeurs
qui sont les nôtres pour notre goût de
la liberté pour cette possibilité sur
notre sol de croire librement et de ne
céder à aucun esprit de terreur
et je le dis avec beaucoup de clarté une
fois encore aujourd'hui nous ne céderons
rien ce matin nous avons décidé
d'augmenter la posture de vigilance
partout en france pour nous adapter à la
menace terroriste
j'ai décidé que nos militaires seront
dans les prochaines heures davantage
mobilisées et nous passerons la
mobilisation dans le cadre de
l'opération sentinelle de 3000 à 7000
militaires sur notre sol nous nous
mettrons ainsi en situation de protéger
tous les lieux de culte en particulier
bien évidemment les églises pour que la
toussaint puisse se dérouler dans les
conditions qui sont dues nous
protégerons aussi nos écoles pour la
rentrée qui vient
demain se tiendra un conseil de défense
nous acteront de nouvelles mesures dans
la continuité de ce que faisons depuis
plusieurs mois dans la continuité de ce
que j'avais annoncé lors du discours des
mureaux et de ce que nous avons ensuite
mise en oeuvre de manière permanente
je veux saluer la mobilisation tout le
gouvernement est tout particulièrement
du ministre de l'intérieur et du garde
des sceaux qui m'accompagnent la cloche
a retenti dans l'église beaucoup
d'émotion à l'heure où je vous parle
alors que des jeunes de toutes
confessions sont en train d'allumer des
bougies devant la basilique notre dame à
nice merci beaucoup
katia on vous retrouvera prochainement
en direct depuis nice